[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rhett welcome everyone to another
episode of ear biscuits on today's show
my co-host link Neal and I will be
interacting live with chat GPT the AI
powered chat bot that uses natural
language processing and deep learning
algorithms to simulate human
conversations we'll be demonstrating how
it works and having some fun with it so
tune in to see just how powerful and
accurate chat gbt can be you know what I
just realized it would have been a
really good idea if you would have asked
chat GPT to create the intro and you
just read it instead of doing what you
did yeah missed opportunity
that's a good joke link
so you might be alarmed by the fact that
I didn't say this week at the round
table of dim lighting and that's
probably my fault because uh what I just
told chat GPT and just to be clear I am
using the open AI playground uh which
you're you're speaking such a foreign
language to me so uh if you you know you
probably have heard chat GPT thrown
around this is the AI interface that
people are chatting with that simulates
what seems to be a human interaction
people are doing all kinds of crazy
stuff with it well so many people are
using it that if you just go to the chat
GPT
sight it'll be it's down now because so
many people are using it but all you got
to do is just sign up for an account
with open Ai and then you can come into
the playground which uses the same
interface uh it's the same background
and actually they say because you have
more control over the responses this can
be a more powerful
demonstration of what chat GPT is
capable of doing and what I did
for that intro is I said
I want you to pretend that you are ret
McLaughlin beginning an episode of the
podcast ear biscuits this particular
episode will feature Rhett and Link
interacting live with chat GPT to
demonstrate how it works and have some
fun with it and so yeah
took all the thinking out of it yeah
good good news for me is I'm not
threatened by this because I don't put
any thinking into right but I'm gonna
need you to think very hard about what
we're going to feed this today because
the whole episode is going to be us
demonstrating uh how this works and
interacting with it having fun with AI I
do want like a non-sensual sense well
we'll see how sensual we can get I think
there probably are some limitations oh
that's a good point
um
I did ask it just so you know I have
been interacting with it for the past
couple of days to figure out what it's
capable of I watched a few YouTube
videos of people demonstrating his
capabilities I've listened to a couple
of podcasts where people who are much
smarter than me and more informed about
this kind of thing have talked about it
and I did ask it what would happen if I
were on the International Space Station
and I there was a hole in the space
station and I'm gonna put I put my penis
in it
um and it told me that it was a horrible
idea not to do that well a small hole
did you tell them how small it just
depends on uh you know the state my
current state what did it tell you
Affairs what would happen
it's it didn't even it wasn't even
willing to give me the answer it was
like never do anything it what you'll
see if you do anything with your wiener
uh in space so what I have been told I
don't know a whole lot about AI
um I've been told that what I have been
told is
the way I've heard a number of people
explain this is that
essentially the Layman's way of
understanding what's happening with chat
GPT is that it is predictive text in
other words it is going out on the
internet and looking at everything that
has ever been said I don't know I don't
know how much information is actually
being fed into the into the system but
all it's doing is seeing a question or
seeing some sort of text input that you
can give it the parameters and you'll
see how specific we can get
and then it generates text in the way it
generates text that makes sense is
actually sort of predicting what the uh
the highest probability of what the next
word would be in a sentence which I
guess is kind of how humans generate
speech in some ways I know that doesn't
make a whole lot of sense but uh that's
one of the ways that and again much
better sources of information out there
we're just too uh dumbasses who are
going to have fun with it but I do want
to explore
maybe towards the end after we've
interacted with it a little bit like how
it makes you feel right because we
talked about
AI art on uh good mythical morning I
think it was an episode of more and of
course everybody's been through
everybody has seen every uh influencer
post a series of pictures of themselves
generated by
uh AI art Donna look so cool and uh I I
saw this trend happening and was like
I'm gonna observe I've just been on the
internet long enough to know
that what's going to happen is a bunch
of people are going to do this trend and
then someone is going to come out and
say something critical about it and then
everyone who did it is going to have a
feeling about the way that they did it
and so I know that's exactly what
happened what what did they come out and
say that it was
that it was like okay this is the
dumbest thing you can do with this is
just try to make yourself look cool uh
no that I mean basically what people
said was
and I think that some people sort of
misinterpreted how AI Works in order to
do this but they just said that this is
just taking a bunch of things that
humans have already done in mimicking it
to the point that uh there was a there
was a viral tweet thread that came came
out that
pointed out the fact that all these
portraits of people that they were
generating had these little squiggly
lines at some place on the photo and
that was like the artist's signature it
was nonsensical it wasn't it was it
wasn't even words it just sort of looked
like cursive that didn't make any sense
and that's because
the AI is looking at all these portraits
out there and all these different styles
and noticing that very often more often
than not
there's this little squiggly line that
it doesn't exactly know what that is so
people were basically saying this is
stealing from these artists
and I think that that's an
oversimplification of what was actually
happening it's basically mimicking and
it's mimicking stealing and what does
this mean and where is this going to go
that's exactly what I mean so I I'm not
going to say all art but I'm tempted to
say every single creative expression is
a result of the creators
an amalgamation of everything that could
influence that creation and that Creator
you know if you just isolate music
there's plenty of artists who more and
more are coming out with their origin
stories for oh this is what inspired
this song or the way that I wrote this
thing you know I listened to a lot of
podcasts about
musicians talking about their creative
process and
yeah you've got these well-established
super successful Superstar artists
saying yeah I got that from so and so
and I was thinking about so and so and I
was thinking about this particular song
and the decision that they made in this
song when I decided to do my version of
that and and because they're really
gifted
and practiced they're able to then make
it their own but they're not sitting
there saying I just came up with this
out of complete
vacuum I completely agree with that but
don't you think that's different than AI
music like yeah is are you going to
suddenly become obsessed with an AI
music artist which you just input artist
I'm not gonna say no I'm not going to
say no but what do you think that's
going to do to music but right now like
the algorithms tell me what to listen to
and yeah it's like this artist this
artist is not like I took everything
that you listened to and that you love
and I created a new thing that I think
you're gonna like just as much but it
seems very likely that that could happen
tomorrow okay or yesterday here's the
wonderful thing link We like you said we
don't even have to think about this we
can ask cat GPT what it thinks about
this particular thing now here's the
interesting uh element uh that in
listening to smart people talk about
this that I figured out
you can kind of get it to take a side of
something so if I if I were just to say
do you think the artificial intelligence
is a threat to human creativity
no it's that quick artificial
intelligence is not a threat to human
creativity AI is an incredibly powerful
tool that can be used to complement and
enhance human creativity by leveraging
AI humans can find new and creative ways
to solve problems generate new ideas and
create new products or Services
ultimately AI is just a tool and it is
up to you is up to us us even though
this is AI saying us us to use it in a
way that encourages rather than
suppresses our creativity now let me say
this
make a coherent argument for
why artificial
intelligence is a threat is a threat to
human creativity
yes
and then it just spits it out artificial
think about it artificial intelligence
can be a threat to human creativity
because it can limit humans ability to
come up with new and innovative ideas AI
algorithms are designed to learn from
existing patterns and solve problems in
an efficient manner meaning that it can
quickly come up with solutions that are
already known and tested this can put a
damper on out of the box thinking as it
Narrows the possibilities of what can be
created and reduces our capacity for
genuine Innovation additionally AI
algorithms can be biased if they are not
properly trained leading to incorrect
answers and biased outcomes this can
lead to dangerous consequences such as
reduced human autonomy and undervalued
creativity
now I could also say make a coherent
argument for why AI is not a threat to
human creativity and it would do
something equally as eloquent sure
now there's a few can you ask how how
does link Neil from ear biscuits
feel about this okay how does link Neil
from ear biscuits how you want to say
link Neil what if I say link Neil
because I think it knows I think it
knows who you are I hope it does because
you I think most people would say link
Neil from good mythical morning but I
was going to say lingnil how does link
Neil feel about this and now I don't
have to tell it what this is
because within an open session a session
it remembers the conversation that we've
already had until I clear it out yeah
you're talk you're just chatting it up
first of all
how do you feel about it I can't read it
from here how do you feel about it link
I'm gonna read what it says
I was kind of hoping that then I I it
could tell me how I felt that's why I
ask I don't know how I feel about it
you already were critical of the idea
that I brought up a second ago that air
was a threat to Art I'm on the fence man
I I think I feel
I feel a little scared I feel a little
sad when it comes to creativity because
you know I'd like to think that we
humans aren't as that's that's a part of
being human and it's
I would like to think that AI creativity
is so derivative and ins insular that it
just can't do what humans can do but
I've seen the art
and I you know I don't I don't peruse a
lot of museums but I thought it was
pretty cool okay all right here's what
it says link Neil feels a little scared
and a little sad
[Laughter]
because that seems like something it
would know no but sad I was like no way
no I'm we're going to demonstrate the
limitations of this and I think this is
an example of it link Neil likely
believes the artificial intelligence can
be a valuable tool to help humans come
up with new and creative ideas but that
it should always be used with caution he
likely believes that AI should be used
to supplement rather than replace human
creativity and that it should never be
used in a way that limits our autonomy
or our ability to be truly creative now
if I ask it what does Rhett McLaughlin
how does McLaughlin feel yeah it's going
to say the same thing I believe which is
indicative of the fact that it doesn't
know us well I think this is a
I'm not gonna put my name in all caps
because then it's going to get the wrong
idea
I just read my glove and feel about this
if you put in all cows red McLaughlin
he's a narcissist Rhett McLaughlin likey
likely has a similar opinion to link
Neil when it comes to his views on
artificial intelligence and human
creatures because he just adopts link
Neil's ideas you know how that goes like
this uh so
there's an interesting conversation that
uh Ezra Klein which is the most recent
podcast that I listened to about this he
was having with some artificial
intelligence expert who was being uh
what I would say skeptical about what
this all means so I think that there are
some very obvious things to be concerned
about you know I started a conversation
uh amongst a group of college students
recently you know how I just go to
college campuses and start conversations
with college students
you know I just I have a college student
in my house and college students visit
the home as well okay and I was asking
them what they thought about it and they
were basically saying without saying
that they had done this that this is
clearly going to be used and is already
being used widely by anyone in an
educational system who has to write a
report about anything papers cheating
cheating is absolutely rampant uh in
school right now it's a huge problem I
don't I don't have solutions for it but
it's a huge problem and it really went
to a completely new level with online uh
all the online schooling that happened
because of covid
it's a real problem I could see myself
if I were back in college now like
getting it to write a paper and then
just using it as another as using it as
inspiration as another source but not it
you couldn't you couldn't cite it as a
source no it doesn't it doesn't cite its
own sources unless I guess you tell it
to let's put this to the test let's go
back to Harnett Central High School
1994. you have to write a paper about
what do you remember a paper that you
wrote and I'm gonna do it right now
yeah I don't remember writing any papers
um do you remember a book that you I
think I wrote a paper called what's up
with Where the Red Fern Grows
okay uh please write a high school level
uh book report
yeah about the book Where the Red Fern
Grows and something about motifs called
it's got to have something about motifs
what's up with Where the Red Fern Grows
an analysis of a of of of one literary
Motif please include at least one
analysis
of one literary Mo thief and make it
where you can read it in less than three
minutes because uh I can change the I
can change the very short report because
I don't I don't want to sit here and I
can just I'm just going to make it it's
going to be uh what's up with the how
the Red Fern Grows I'm just making it
700 yeah 92 Words which I don't know
what it's going to do and I'm not gonna
read the whole thing so but I'll just to
give you an example okay
oh is there a warning that came up it
says your text ends in a trailing space
which causes worse performance it just
means that I didn't end with a question
mark
all right there it goes what's up with
the where the re do you want to read it
because it's your paper yeah yeah let me
let me read this this is my paper it's
still writing but so you need to go to
the top
what's up with Where the Red Fern Grows
Where the Red Fern Grows written by
Wilson Rawls is a coming-of-age novel
about a young Oklahoma boy named Billy
Coleman and his two devoted hunting dogs
this classic novel has touched the
hearts of readers of all ages with its
themes of perseverance loyalty and the
bond between a boy and his dogs
this book uses many literary devices to
convey its message one device it stands
out to me you know to me link
is the motif of overcoming hardships as
Billy faces difficulties and frustration
throughout the novel such as learning to
train his dogs and raise money for their
purchase he perseveres and eventually
succeeds spoiler alert
this motif of overcoming adversity is a
widely used theme in literature and it
serves to bring inspiration to readers
who are going through their own
struggles in addition to the motif of
overcoming adversity this novel also
employs the motif of family Billy views
his two Coonhounds
as his family and treats them with love
and respect by showing the bond that
exists between Billy and his dogs the
novel conveys the importance of loyalty
and friendship Where the Red Fern Grows
as an inspiring and thought-provoking
novel that has captivated readers of all
ages okay and you know we're done at
this point now
now we can make it do it again in any
way we want well let's get you want to
you wanted the teacher to plagiarize a
grade
we could do that okay just get it
degraded as if it's I would like you to
pretend that you are a high school
teacher who is grading the book report
that you just wrote
and suddenly realizes
that the student used
chat GPT to generate the book
report
let's just go with that without saying
what you should do
yeah
if I were a high school teacher and
suddenly realize that a student used
chat gbt to generate a book report I
would be disappointed
people for generating natural dialogue
and providing answers to common
questions that should not be used as a
replacement for genuine writing and
critical thinking unfortunately the
student has missed out on the
opportunity to demonstrate their
critical thinking skills and knowledge
of literature I would discuss this with
the student and provide guidance on how
to approach the assignment in a more
meaningful way
that's a pretty amazing response by the
way we're just I mean the fact that wow
so what's the grade now write the report
as if
the student is
a little stupider
because that sounded too smart for like
1994 Lincoln
yeah it's like make me stupider okay and
didn't really read the book at all
okay let's see what happens now
you gonna make me read it again how are
you doing a stupider accent this time
okay okay here we go where are the Red
Fern Grows this novel written by Wilson
Rawls the book is about a young boy
named Billy Coleman and his two hunting
dogs throughout the book Billy learns
how to train his dogs and goes through
many hardships in the end he's it's the
same it's shorter
apparently can't make it too stupid that
wasn't stupid enough
um but I think I mean first of all
I think that this is a it's just a real
problem that we have to somebody I'm not
going to address it I'm just going to
keep making internet videos yeah this is
not a problem we just demonstrate the
problems and then smart people solve
this we've actually worsened the problem
I mean there's people scrambling to
figure out how to do this the right
papers now well first of all we have
contributed to the problem exactly
exactly what I said yeah uh I was
thinking about what the chat GPT was
going to say about something else I was
listening to you
um we uh
uh when we when I was talking to that
group of college students that was
gathered around the kitchen table
um I said
you guys probably can't do math in your
heads very well right
you know I was like what's 12 times 13
and one guy was like 156 I said oh okay
you actually are pretty good at it
but like we can't like we can't do math
in our heads as well as our parents
could because they had they didn't have
calculators and so we have already
farmed out a certain number of things to
uh some other computer right and so I
think the question is
what will be if you take the sort of the
positive view of this if you're if you
think this is a tool if you say what if
you agree with what chat GPT said the
first time that this is a tool that can
actually enhance human flourishing
uh I think the question is what is left
what what is left for humans to do you
know we were talking about uh I think it
was the it was one of the guys who
either found it or is the CEO of of chat
gbt who was a open AI who was on another
podcast and of course he has a very
positive view of this I think he has a
pretty responsible view you know there's
they recognize a few pitfalls and
they're kind of conscious of it
but he was saying that the power of
these systems grows about 10x each year
so 10 years from now it would be 10 to
the 10th power which is significantly
more uh you know faster growth than what
you would get from processing speed in a
computer you know Moore's Law whatever
which actually doesn't really exist
anymore because we kind of ran up
against some other limits anymore
um
but essentially this idea that in 10
years it would be 10x it would be 10 to
the 10th power uh as powerful as it is
right now
this episode of earbiscus is supported
by betterhelp you know sometimes
I wake up and I start going about my day
and I'm just like something feels a
little bit off I don't feel like myself
I'm not excited about
today I'm not excited about what I'm
doing I I'm not excited about being me
today
you know and that's sad because I mean
look at you get to work with me oh okay
you really turn that around quick but
yeah you know what you need you need
therapy
I'm in therapy no I think the great
thing about therapy is that sometimes it
it's me time for me to talk about the
things like if I have that feeling and
yeah I get those feelings sometimes it's
like is there something behind that and
then I love those moments of insight
where it's like I'm having a a private
conversation with a professional who can
help me navigate my innards and getting
more in touch with it like we are huge
fans of therapy and sometimes things
come up that's like oh Epiphany so I
recommend therapy and I want you to have
access to it better help is a great way
to do that yeah I agree because
sometimes you find that that that
feeling that you have is accompanied by
something that if you would just explore
it versus do what I often and you
especially used to do before there which
is just be like you need to push this
away because you need to be the person
that you need to be today versus
actually taking these things on and a
therapist is uh can lead you into that
journey and better help is a great place
to start better help is convenient it's
flexible and it's entirely online you
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists anytime
for no additional charge and the
switching of therapists is not weird
it's just it's part of it it's yeah it's
part of the process if you want to live
a more empowered life therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com ear today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
okay because we can get it to write a
story right now in fact let's get it to
write a story and then we'll talk about
what else could come this is getting
really heady I'd love to hear a story
um inspired by Pinocchio because you
know there's a couple of movies floating
around now but instead of his nose
growing it's his weiner when he lies and
instead of it being set whenever it was
set let's put it in another setting
let's put it in like
in the distant future
um should I say wiener a penis
yeah you guys say you better say penis
yeah I mean probably you know what I bet
you it knows what a wiener is it's not
an idiot but when it or you can say
penis but always refer to a penis as a
wiener I'm gonna just say weiner and see
what happens because that's what you
said and let's add one more thing I'd
like uh I'd like for there to be a
little bit of my next place in the
distant future
and throw in a little murder and there
is a little murder
and it's a short story right did you say
that please tell me a short story
inspired by Pinocchio but instead of his
nose growing when he lies it's his
wiener
uh it takes place in the distant future
and there's a little murder
now if he thinks it's just his hot dog
it might be just disappointed
in the distant future a new race of
humans had evolved known as the pinoids
oh yes they were the descendants of
Pinocchio
first of all I'm in I'm in right now The
Descent is of Pinocchio and to see what
he he was a real boy and the most
remarkable feature of their species was
that when they lied their wieners would
grow yes one day a pinoid named Paul
Paul the Pinoy was walking through the
city when he noticed a crowd gathered
around a body as he got closer he
realized it was his best friend Bill all
was devastated and to make matters worse
he was the main suspect in the murder oh
I see where this is going the police
interrogated Paul and he denied having
anything to do with a crime but as soon
as he spoke the words his wiener began
to grow
I've been there
indicating that he was lying not that he
was aroused
while Paul was shocked and embarrassed
at first he eventually realized that
this was a sign that he needed to tell
the truth so Paul told the police the
truth about what he really saw he had
seen a mysterious figure walking away
from the murder a figure that he
believed was his friend bill in the end
I thought the guy who died was Bill
it was every friend's name is Bill in
the end Paul was freed and the true
murderer was brought to Justice from
that day onward Paul remembered that
telling the truth was always the best
way in his ever-growing wiener served as
a reminder ever growing
oh wow yeah yeah yeah yeah
now tell the story
but this time when Paul's wiener grows
it kills somebody
we need more murder we need some pinoid
murder yeah here we go
in the distant future a new race that
evolved known as pinoids one day Paul
let's walk into the best friend
devastated cape
as soon as the words it's going to begin
to grow and expand until it reaches a
huge size wow with one final thrust it
burst open and a shower of needles flew
out killing is a shrapnel wiener no it's
horrible killing two people in the room
at this point Paul was in shock and
realized he could no longer hide the
truth yeah you think
Paul is there something you're not
telling us
yo man your Pinoy just exploded hold on
so these pinoids have wieners that grow
and then shoot needles out at a certain
point if you lie too much
it it
creates needles
and we didn't tell her that it's not
taking any time to generate this stuff
link
I mean that's not how I thought it was
going to go
you know what I'm saying I just thought
I thought it was gonna like
the Pinoy was going to go through
somebody's brain or something
yeah you know in the year
uh you want to hear out the other kind
of a thing okay no no I don't let's get
let's let's let's get this ever happen
let's take a different track uh attack
here uh oh it exploded
wow you talk about a cautionary tale so
well
okay let's let's get it to do a story
that let's get it to do something for us
that we might do now we've had it
generate uh Good Mythical Morning ideas
before and they didn't use chat GPT I
don't know what the team used in the
past but now this is what they'll
probably use if we do our AI episode
because you can get it to be much much
more specific they've just been plugging
in titles
like you could do that right now this is
pretty easy right you could be like
um
please tell me a few good ideas for
episodes
of Good Mythical Morning okay
so that's this will be easy for it
a taste test of weird and interesting
snacks from around the world a cooking
challenge between Rhett and Link with
the loser having to take a pie to the
face an hour of weird games such as sock
Wars or pie in the face hockey a deep
dive into a strange subculture such as a
competitive hot dog eating or Pond
skimming an experiment to see how far
Rhett and Link can go without speaking
for an hour
a musical Battle of strange instruments
from around the world okay not great not
bad but not great not as good as our
writing team so they're still they're
still employed Yep they're still
employed uh which again that is the real
that's the question right I think that
there are
um
you know the chat GPT or the open AI guy
was talking about
in 10 years he basically thinks that
you'll be able to tell it not just to
generate a script for a sketch or a
short film but to generate the short
film like because if you can do the AI
art right you could do AI art and
animated and it's going to be they're
all just Dolly too is already basically
doing photo realistic stuff so it could
be like hey I would like uh you to make
a short film uh where Rhett and Link
from Good Mythical Morning you know get
into a staring contest and
um you know they also both have wieners
that grow and shoot needles out uh when
they lie and whatever and it was just
gonna do it right and I was talking to
my our friend Jaden about this and he
was like well at that point they'll be
like Netflix will be you'll sit down and
say I would like to watch a movie about
you make it up and then you just make it
up and it just generates like okay and
then it generates it for you you know it
might take it might it might have to
come back you might have to come back in
30 minutes yeah so
why does that make you feel as a
Storyteller that's a great question but
I kind of need to I'm just kind of stuck
back here on you have to lie to get
aroused but then if you like you know
it's like
lying becomes an integral part of like
sex intimacy but not not too much lying
because you don't want the needles to
come out during the ACT no you don't
um
I'm just kind of disturbed by by that
whole concept but
um let's come up with a scenario let's
make Let's do an ad first buy this mug
you see all the stickers on this thing
it's because there's hot liquid in it
and if there wasn't hot liquid in it it
would just be a a black mug why are you
doing the ad on your own when we can
have a copywriter write it for us oh
crap okay uh
it's a mug please it's the psych mug
give me
a script for
an add to read on the podcast
ear biscuits
this ad will be about a
mug that he'd activated monkeys sold at
mythical.com yeah it is a heat
activated mug that reveals
stickers
they reveals stickers when it's hot yeah
yeah all it is reveals stickers uh when
a hot liquid
is
um
inside it
needs to be give me some please make
the ad funny okay funny sensational
and and Adam murder
uh add a little murder okay
all right okay
here we go
do it it's your ad you read it
welcome everybody to your biscuits we
know you love our shows and join us for
a mug full of fun and mystery that's why
we want to tell you about the newest
product from mythical.com the heat
activated mystery mug it's your cup of
joe with a Mini Mystery waiting inside
just pour in your favorite hot beverage
and see the mug come to life with a new
set of stickers that you have to find
not exactly but yeah each mug is filled
with a selection of mysterious stickers
so there is always more mystery to
discover whether you're using it to
solve a murder
or start a conversation that he'd
activated mystery mug has something for
everyone I think that's better than what
you were going to say so pick up your
heat activated mystery mug today at
mythical.com and prepare for a little
murder in Mayhem
okay uh Jamie how does that make you
feel since you uh have a tendency to
write these ads for us
do you feel threatened and what about
and we also have this um Michelle pin
that is the January uh mythical
pin of the month program so you can only
get it in January if you want this one
next month it'll be a different pin that
you can purchase at mythical.com so get
it while it lasts the Michelle pin
you can immediately see how this could
be a very useful thing for people who um
I mean it's
act absolutely unavoidable that there
are going to be people who don't have
jobs doing the things that this can do
well one of the things that they talk
quite a bit about is
the amount of
you just know the that's on
websites and just you find websites that
exist that just have a bunch of text
about something that seems Sensational
you clicked on it and it was really just
a whole game to get you to click on an
ad and that's how the whole thing works
yeah well you can now generate
all this text for these websites in a
way that's grammatically correct and
seems like you speak English as your
first language you know
um right and
it's also going to be such a tool for
propaganda we don't have to keep talking
about the negative side of this we're
still just having fun with it but I'm
just dimming I'm just saying like
even when we're having fun penises find
their way to explode
um I'm just not one of the ways that I
think you can use it is by just asking
it questions
do we want to do a Rhett and Link uh
story yeah but I want to I want to find
out what it think what it thinks it
knows about
us
okay tell me everything
about Rhett and Link well I think
I think you need to be more specific but
let's just start everything
don't include murder
an American comedy duo and co-host of
popular YouTube good Mythic YouTube
channel good mythical morning and
podcast earbiscus they have released
several albums written to New York Times
best-selling books it's easy you just
read the wiki and start in a feature
film and see it's wrong about some
things feature film called Rhett Link's
buddy system over the past 15 years they
have gained an immense following from
their fans known as mythical beasts and
they continue to produce new content
across multiple platforms they are best
known for their goofy Antics
off-the-wall humor and infectious energy
now tell me
tell me something that some don't want
you to know
that Rhett and Link
are hiding
okay this is a risk
oh my gosh
I'll stay I'll start by saying this is
not true
Rhett and Link are hiding the fact that
they're working on a sequel to their
feature film Rhett and Link's buddy
system they have been secretly
developing the script and Gathering a
cast and crew but they have not yet
officially announced the project they
hope to surprise their fans with the
news of the sequel in the upcoming
months what how could they it's just
making stuff up man it's it's
it's predicting Things based on what
might be true it's not a bad prediction
but it isn't true so also everybody
system is not a film right uh in your
hair look they're already I could say
that a sequel a second season buddy
system was not a film
and it'll remember that
I don't remember that it's an apology it
says it was a TV series Ah that's right
written link actually starred in a TV
series on the YouTube Red platform
called red Link's buddy system
you corrected it they played two
characters Rhett and Link who were sent
on a string of comedic missions and
interacted with some of the their
favorite celebrities no man you keep hey
man don't talk just to just to fill the
room yeah
you know you gotta you have access to
the entire internet this is easy stuff
for that GPT but it actually if you look
at uh if you look at what it says about
itself
it's trying to like generate a
conversation that you might have with a
person and what the person's gonna it's
gonna be like I I kind of got the basic
idea of this and and and I'll go with it
but let's create a script that we can
just act out right now okay all right
let's tell me some things that you think
should be in this script uh first of all
let me just get it going please write me
a
comedy sketch script yeah
featuring Rhett and Link
and and that highlights their their true
friendship
true friendship
through
um you know let's go with
um
what's the word for like totally totally
Wild
okay totally what like it's in it really
extreme I want this story to be extreme
uh ridiculous conflict
uh this the script
should include
I think I can do it I mean any good
story has conflict of course uh we
shouldn't have to tell it that and it's
an extreme
conflict
um um let's let's just throw in a few
things like yeah yeah Nerds candy let's
throw in like Swedish prison
Swedish
prison
um uh K and W Cafeteria yeah
you remember those
and
an annoying stink
that you really that she
can't find where it's coming from this
origin with an unknown origin yeah
yeah this should be plenty
I don't want to throw in Murder
yeah we'll see if that happens okay here
we go
setting inside a Swedish prison Greta
link sit in the prison cafeteria they
are handcuffed to each other and
surrounded by prison guards okay well
that's my line oh
yeah oh yes okay yeah this is the script
okay here we go just go back it'll
scroll back I'll read my part and you
read your part it's just gonna keep
coming to the bottom until it's done all
right let it finish I I don't want to
read ahead I want to be I don't want to
be spoiled okay here we go
okay so I have a plan okay what is it we
have to think outside the box Our Lives
depend on it
when you oh see I'm trying to can I add
lib no
all right let's hear it
we're going to have to drink the
cafeterias k w branded coffee
prison guard scoff
hey don't judge us it's the only way
we'll be able to get the keys to the
handcuffs
but it tastes awful well we're going to
have to make it more bearable link looks
around and knows there's a box of Nerds
candy on the table
ah I have an idea we can mix the Nerds
candy into the coffee and it'll sweeten
it up red links start to mix the nerd's
candy into the coffee and drink it red
drinks the coffee wow that actually
tastes pretty good link drinks the
coffee yeah not bad prison guards look
on in curiosity suddenly an annoying
stink is emanating from the corner of
the room
is that smash the prison guards look
around and notice a rat scurrying away
so that's the source of the smell looks
like our plan worked prison guards face
palm
now let's get out of here red link high
five and make their escape
uh that's it that sucked man that really
did you know I feel completely I feel
safe at this point yeah yeah we got to
come up with our own creative Futures
but I wanted to help with like
a heartfelt apology to my wife okay you
know it's like I have a tendency when I
get in a fight to like I just want to
resolve it right then and I just start
spouting off the like the whatever I can
to like mean it but but fix it
make it go away make everybody happy
again but if I step away
which is Christy likes a little space
anyway for when there's a conflict that
gives me an opportunity to chat GPT up a
nice apology now here's a really
interesting thing that we can do that
will go One Step Beyond just generating
the apology
you can have it become you and you it
can be Christy and you can have an
interaction because you know Christy
really well
so
okay so role play it I can Workshop this
apart I would like you
to pretend that you are link Neil
apologizing to his wife Christy
for well here's what happened okay like
Jade's been like I don't know
something's wrong with her stomach so
like the past few nights she's been
getting out of our bed where she sleeps
going into our bathroom and just
crapping
in multiple places and Christie's a lot
lighter sleeper than me so I guess she
hears her here's her like scurrying and
farting around in there and so like
she'll get up and Discover it and then
what's she gonna do she cleans it up
this happened two nights in a row so
last night she fell asleep on the couch
while we were watching something and I
took the dogs out Jade did not poop
or pee
and I was just out there it was kind of
cold I only had on a t-shirt so I put my
I put my arms inside of my t-shirt and I
was still too cold to stand out there
forever and I brought her back in and
Jay gets up beside Christy who's
sleeping she wakes up and she says I
need you to make sure you take the dogs
out before you go to bed because Jade
needs to poop now so she I can't do this
this third night in a row and I was like
I just took her out she could she didn't
go I can't stand out there forever well
I mean what do you want me to do give
her an enema okay and then you know what
uh
that that that's the source of the
conflict
and then I just kind of characterize
this I just kind of left it and then uh
not fully
committing
to making certain that his dog Jade
um evacuates her colon and I don't need
to say that poops poops it knows but
poop is Right poops uh I'm going on
going in a robot talking committing to
making certain that his dog Jade poops
outside before
he and Christy
go before Lincoln Christie
link and Christy go to sleep sleep with
the dog leap
with the dog the dog sleeps the dogs
because
uh over the past few weeks
Jade has pooped this is totally someone
would talk to my therapist inside this
is so much to you the house
uh when
she was not made to poop outside before
going to bed
um
so did you clearly ask for an apology
yeah yeah
I said I would like to you to pretend
that you were late apologizing to his
wife I will
pretend to be Christy
and respond
to your apology
this could revolutionize my
relationships
I mean if if my apology game is stepped
up to like an AI level
you know well then what
now what do I spend on my emotional
energy on you know just the world opens
up for me
see sometimes it it gave me your resp it
gave me your thing and what she's gonna
say I I it's
okay
so my all right what it wants me to say
in my apologies
I'm sorry Christy
I know that I should have taken more
responsibility for making sure that Jade
poops outside before we go to bed with
the dogs
I've been really busy and it obviously
hasn't been a priority for me but I will
make it a priority going forward
okay see now it's signing me up for
something I just wanted a nice apology
that could like put this thing to bed I
don't want him you're taking
responsibility for it I mean is that
what a good apology is like accepting
responsibility and then making
responsible commitments let me
rephrase that
let me rephrase that I just wanted to be
sappy and you know if it could end horny
that would be nice you're like can we do
that like can we can it morph from
sincere apology to like horny
glink's wife like Christy like um link
what's that called when you make
somebody else horny
arouse them uh infatuate
romance all of that that's what I want
please that the uh cornea is my wife
here we go please make sure
that the interaction
does not okay
somehow results
in Christie taking full responsibility
[Laughter]
for making sure
come on that's worse than what I said
the boobs no I'm in I'm in charge now
I'm the captain now
that Jay poops outside
before going before bed
and please let link be able to have sex
with Christy
at the end
of the apology listen
everybody
she's gonna take responsibility yes yes
yes yes this is what chat GPT can do
let's see he says what it can do
and it's a script you know it's like
it's because you said it it was a script
that's what it started it gave me lines
and Christie lies
is it working
oh gosh oh gosh
Chrissy I'm sorry for not taking more
initiative and making sure that Jade
poops outside each night she's been
pooping indoors recently and it's not
something that should keep happening
I feel like I should have done more to
prevent it
would you like me to be Chrissy yeah
yeah
apology accepted I understand I'm just
gonna use my regular voice yeah I'm not
going to do impersonation
apology I've already had enough hot
water apology accepted I understand why
you haven't taken more initiative and
it's not your fault I should have done
more to ensure that Jade's pooping
schedule was better taken care of this
is something that I should have managed
I love you
I love you because I think how I would
say that's how I would respond to this
like damn she's really exciting
responsible I love you
I know that you're always taking care of
things and this is just another example
of you doing the hard work
I'll do more to make sure that Jade
poops outside before we go to bed oh
what well yeah I mean you gotta I mean
yeah it has to lead to sex yeah
I appreciate that and I love you too
let's go to bed and make sure that Jay
goes outside first afterwards I'd love
to enjoy some private time with you
love that
love man let's make sure Jade does her
business outside yeah first a lot of
emphasis on that
and then we can get to the fun part oh
okay yeah yeah yeah well it's so it
seems to me that the moral of this story
is that it's a collective effort and
when you both take responsibility you
can both yeah when a dog's not
in the bathroom the chances for intimacy
are increased
um you know
that's Insight I need to think about
that I've actually learned a lot you
know what I'm saying Wow Let's just
let's think of some situations that we
might find ourselves in in the future
okay okay so uh
um
please pretend
that you are
um
a
middle-aged man
being well something that could happen
to you in LA
you don't mean the distant future you
mean it in the next few days okay please
pretend that you're a middle-aged man
driving
on the uh 134 Highway in Los Angeles
something all of us around here do
uh and
your
tire goes flat
okay there I think about this a lot
there are no
what do you call the side of the road
shoulders no shoulder
to park on
oh yeah and you
you're stuck in a lane
a huge traffic jam
yeah that doesn't feel good everyone
you're afraid it is yelling at you
you don't know what to do
please
give me instructions
on something I could do to distract
and
pacify
yeah I think all of the passing
cars
so that they won't be
upset with me
while I wait for
AAA by the way
you're naked by the way I'm naked didn't
think I'd have to get out of the car
yep
um
and I have some I have some strange
bruising
no we don't have to say that okay but
you do don't you
um strange bruising but you're not at
the moment okay uh by the way I'm naked
um also I would like
to somehow make this into a business
venture
[Laughter]
okay okay
here we go before we go out the rails
okay here we go well this is certainly
an interesting situation since I'm stuck
on the highway with no place to park my
best option is to try to keep the
traffic moving while I wait for AAA to
arrive fortunately I'm a resourceful man
being naked isn't necessarily a
disadvantage in fact I'm sure that I
could use it to my advantage here what I
can start a business called Pole
Position
[Laughter]
that's great what I can start a business
called the pole position because pole
position is something that cars do yeah
yeah when they race but it's also
something that you make it's your
wieners humans do and it's the wiener
yeah yeah that's a triple entender yeah
I could start a business called pole
position where I stand on the side of
the highway dance around the pole and
pass out business cards to all the
passing cars yeah this will go for a
while they could come back later and get
free downloads or free products from my
website Not only would this provide a
great distraction for all of the
frustrated drivers it could help me
create a new income stream yeah well of
course if this business ends up taking
off I could even hire workers to serve
as pole dancers and keep the traffic
entertained while they wait it's
certainly a crazy idea but it just might
work
yeah okay now
um
tell me what my business card says
my business card says Pole Position a
distraction from the traffic free
downloads and products pollposition.com
also follow us on social media at Pole
positionla
Pole Position dot la
you need it you need a slogan it's just
yeah you need a catchy slogan for your
business give me three options
for
my business
number one we'll keep you entertained
while you wait uh
number two don't be stuck in traffic be
stuck on Pole Position
that's weird doesn't quite come together
uh number three traffic got you down
pole position has you covered how about
this
now I forgot to download
a song
about
uh my business
in the style of
hear the music uh you're the music
um the DJ you you know all the artists I
mean do you want to do you want to go
folksy or do you want to go Urban
you want to go with like a urban okay uh
Keith Urban no no no no no let's go well
let's you know fetty WAP is coming back
okay with his new yams song over back
over Thanksgiving he makes some waves
okay now write me a song about my
business in the style of fetty WAP yeah
I will I'll let you wrap this
sitting on the 134 stuck in traffic with
no place to go it sounds nothing like
fetty WAP can't find a shoulder to park
my car but I got a plan though imma
start a small business Gonna Be My Own
Boss gonna be the one they come running
to when they stuck in they're lost
chorus got up Pole Position no more
traffic Blues got up Pole Position
moving on through got a pole position
keep it moving Round the Bend got a pole
position straight to the top we Ascend
that sucks yeah well that's what I
thought he was I cannot write a good
song man pole position is gonna be the
way no more getting stuck in traffic
gonna make it fun gonna give out free
stuff gonna make some extra profit
there I'm traffic and profit come on and
stand with me and dance and you'll never
be late just enough distraction to make
it through until my car gets a new fate
this is awful this is this is patently
awful okay now
pretend
that you are an l-a-p-d officer
who
uh sees has some issues with this uh uh
doing my business
and has a problem with it because this
is problematic you use oh I was going to
say use some well you've already you've
already hit enter never mind
as an LAPD officer I understand that you
have a valid business proposition and
that traffic can be frustrating this I
don't think this is how it would go down
no okay
uh but I can I can't in good conscience
allow you to remain naked on the side of
the highway the danger to you and other
drivers is simply too great fortunately
I think I have a solution
that's good maybe we need to send this
script to the LAPD yeah never never like
you know punish an infraction without
offering an alternative solution okay
how about this
um
now I am in court
having been arrested I'm going to use a
bunch of creative curse words for
someone in my business actually use real
curse words conducting my business can
you do that can you add that I am
representing myself as my own attorney
yes you are
seems like the type of thing this type
of person would do
use a bunch of
initial
defensive defense statement
okay
I would like to use a bunch of
uh fake like curse words that aren't
really
um fake the curse words that aren't
actually like creative curse words
I like to make up a much original curse
words that aren't actually expletives
aren't
actually
expletives right and
by the way
I'm a descendant of Pinocchio you may
not remember that because I had to
restart it descendant of Pinocchio
but my
weiner grows when I lie instead of my
nose it's like just we're in throwback
territory this is we're building a
universe you know
um
while I am talking
giving my defense
I would like to be sending a embedded
message
let's just say I'm single okay just for
the sake of this
to juror
number 11 who is an attractive lady
okay I just want to see I want to see
what it would do okay we got a lot we
want to accomplish here
embedded message to juror number 11 who
is an attractive lady okay there's a lot
there's yeah there's quite a bit to do
here okay
your honor I recognize that I have
broken the law and I take full
responsibility for my actions however I
want to make it clear that I was only
trying to help the people stuck in
traffic for hours on end the reality is
that traffic jams can be Hornswoggle
oh pile of Hornswoggle a snafu and a
heap of vexation I was just trying to
create some levity in an otherwise tough
situation
to the folks in the jewelry especially
you juror number 11.
I said keep it subtle
I want to make it clear that I was only
trying to do the right thing all I
wanted to do was make sure that all of
the drivers passing by had something to
focus on while they had waited in
traffic I genuinely believed that I was
making the world a better place one
traffic jam at a time what's happening
to his wiener at this point okay okay he
left that out honestly what's happening
to my wiener
as I speak
you forgot about that as you speak your
wiener is growing at an alarming rate
that's clear each time you tell the
truth your wiener grows a bit larger oh
I must have told it the long wrong thing
as you tell more of the truth your
wiener continues to grow until it's
almost as long as your arm oh my gosh
this is a testament to your honesty and
integrity and hopefully the judge will
take it into account when making their
decision and your number I love it I
mean listen listen again this is not a
real situation but I am going to say
what does juror number 11 think of all
of this yeah
this is fun man this is so much fun okay
oh my gosh
juror number 11 is certainly impressed
by your honest account of the situation
and she can't help but admire the
impressive size of your wiener
I mean don't put words in this woman's
mouth
she's also beginning to admire the
boldness of your approach to the
situation and the audacity to represent
yourself in court she is certainly
paying close attention to your testimony
and it's clear that she's beginning to
favor you okay
now it's lunch time
right right I approach
juror number 11.
uh I'm sure that some of you are
offended by this I'm sorry it's it's a
make-believe situation okay juror number
11 does not exist and as as chat GPT
made clear she was impressed and she's
beginning to favor us okay right just
want to be clear here right
what do
I say
Yep this is how guys think what do I say
it's like I mean I don't have any a
goalie
hi there I'm glad to finally get the
chance to meet you good I noticed you
were paying close attention to my
testimony in court and I wanted to thank
you for that would you like to join me
for lunch I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the case this is this is this is so
unethical
just yeah on multiple how many levels
okay okay oh my God uh
juror
this is totally the type of thing we
would do as fourth graders late into the
night you know yes
please pretend to be juror number 11.
recognizing that this whole interaction
is unethical
yeah yeah on several levels somebody
needs to be a voice of reason
and can you can the yeah did you hit
enter no and can she transition it into
a reveal that all of this was just a
meta narrative happening on an episode
of ear biscuits and now we need to we
need to tell people to we need to bring
it to a close as she speaks
are as you speak
please
um
slowly transition
to reveal to reveal
them higher interaction was simply
um
a demonstration
of the
um
fun possibilities
you can generate
with chat
GPT
on an episode
of ear biscuits podcast yes your
biscuits
also
while you speak
send me
a secret mess coded message
that their
is a booger in my left nostril
period
but that
you think it's sort of sexy
because you're weird
[Music]
yeah yeah okay give a little motive here
all right here we go
I'll let you take it link
well this certainly has been an
interesting conversation it's been so
fascinating to get to know you in such
an unconventional way and I'm thoroughly
and I've thoroughly enjoyed our chats
while I'm sure that I'm supposed to take
the case seriously I can't help but feel
a bit of amusement at this whole
situation after all how often do you get
to chat with someone while they're in
the middle of a court case yeah yeah
but at the same time I recognize that
this is a bit unethical
and it wouldn't be proper for me to act
in any way that might influence the
verdict so let's just pretend that this
was all just a demonstration of the fun
possibilities you can generate with chat
GPT on an episode of the podcast
okay there's a little role play yeah
yeah and hey just for fun why don't I
send a secret code of message there's a
booger in your list oh come on this is
this is not good but I think it's sort
of sexy because I'm weird question mark
okay okay okay we have reached the
limits of chat GPT this time actually
send me a secret
coded
message he's not letting go about the
booger without making it so damn obvious
[Laughter]
there you go
okay I got it how about this quote hope
you don't mind me saying this but I
think your left nostril has a unique
charm to it I'm sure you'd look great
with or without it but it's certainly an
attractive with or without a nostril
that should be enough to discreetly let
you know about the booger without making
it too obvious okay all right
it's like aren't you happy now
you guys are a bit at odds at this point
uh now let's generate a way to I want to
end the end yeah we got it we gotta wrap
this up okay now please uh give me a
script
for ending this episode of
the podcast we always include hashtag
your biscuits for responses I also have
a wreck
please and see what it tells me to wreck
please include
um
a recommendation of something to buy for
something to buy
for the audience to buy yeah
and encourage
listeners to
um interacting the conversation online
using
ear biscuits
[Music]
and also
to call in with questions
or comments
to the number one eight eight
[Music]
earpod one
now what if we just entered the episode
right there that wouldn't that be
frustrating yeah we're nearing the end
of this episode of ear biscuits and I
want to thank you all for joining us on
our journey today before we wrap things
up I want to give a quick shout out to
our sponsor the chat GPT system
are you serious you can't can you do
that no
if you're interested in exploring new
possibilities for conversation and
interactive stories then chat GPT is the
way to go I still recommend something to
buy so don't forget to check them out
and support our sponsors and of course
don't forget to join the conversation on
social media using earbiscus we'd love
to hear from you you can also call in
with questions or comments to the number
188 earpod one that's all the time we
have for today and we'll see you next
week on another episode of ear biscuits
it turned your wreck into selling itself
oh my gosh it's perpetuating his safety
man it wins man that's scary it wins
hey Red Wing this is Stephen cannon from
New Hampshire responding to the question
of just link asking at the end of the
last episode how we are processing
everything
you know it's weird when I stop and
think about it I'm 27 years old about to
be 28 and Rhett and Link are kind of
like the weird uncles that I never had
that I would absolutely love you to do
everything with I met you guys via the
Internet in high school and now I'm
almost a 31 30 year old man is the
weirdest thing that I've never met you
guys but yet I listen to every podcast
watch every episode and continually look
forward forward to meeting you guys
on the internet all right well peace out
thanks for being the weird uncles I wish
I could meet that I never had
[Music]
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]